On that day,
everyone in the world
became a doctor.
From material to the sofa today
Thank you 1009 Lesse Please support me even 1 mm This hand is different
After all which one
?  It's a so-called love drug that activates the heart to the extreme
This guy is 10 billion percent after taking
it.
It
's gasoline. Think about the molecular structure of polyethylene, which is produced from the cap of a plastic bottle.
If you
did that, would
n't
Taiki-kun have died?  It's 300 yen to get a bill
, 500 yen to be shaken at full power, 10,000 yen is enough if you can't be a guide.
Listen, it's an advantage, Mr.
Strengthening the store,
I'm going through this, big
,
non,
and low
[music]
Finally, the 9 muscles are always for my sister to
receive
raider
rar
me
[music]
wh
goo
me
[music]
trust  If I'm an intern for even a little bit, I'll break
down unintentionally I'll be fine if I'm in the 3rd group I'm sure I'll be fine
How many months has there been a monkey
tee
Not today
Betsy
[music]
How many decades, hundreds, thousands of years since then?
Chotto non a
4 days
re
ah  The murderous intent that I broke into my love Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Unless the topography has changed drastically, he should be able to put it on - at
that camphor tree
[music]
Wow, I have a child
Turin
donate a car and build a house
A friend posted a picture that he saw it in another place
Cute Sony might be a bird's second product that makes Sifu stiff like this
Yeah, it's
finally in the front, isn't
it?  Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah,
I've seen such a silly figure more than the moon, so I'm going to stick it on the spring water
[music]
And here's another embarrassed child who doesn't think about it
Ah,
Bach
none
Day and time big
ah ah ah
ne
[music]
Blackmail
[MUSIC]
Hmmm, I followed along well, the poison
was so bad, Yuzuriha protected me from being washed away and broken.
I was the one who was on the
trail, so I was able to live
.
[Music]
I loved it I'll help you
for hundreds,
thousands of years
You there
I don't know how to do it right now
I got up, but my shoes were lowered.
I wake up and work,
that is, that day  Roughly
3,700 years have passed.
Don't peak around the 800,000-second cycle
Look at it when it's getting easier
Count while thinking No Use it in parallel
116,400,000,000 Yen 270,006,534 Yo
Finally
6 In
that darkness,
forever Mencius's will  Even if I wake up with my power, it's a part of the winter Two people the media
Food procurement is an immediate game over perl Absolute conditions for the rest of the starting station
Accurate calendar was absolutely necessary information
Look at me,
c'mon  I ca
n't get enough of the number
I'm working alone I'm just building the foundation for a living and
I can't get enough of my physical strength to advance to the civilization ahead
I've been doing it all this time  Yo,
it's because I knew that a lot of the percent
were alive.Yuzuriha couldn't hold out for a few thousand years with half-heartedness.
I'll leave the rest of the work to you, and leave the
use of my body to me.
The three factions will be rescued,
but two high school kids will create civilization from scratch
It's an argument for this stone world alarm Yes, that's it,
ana 2
Yes, what kind of cheat is your physical strength?
Wow, far away Tsuruta z Aug No voice, joint edible, mustard mushrooms Are you far away?
Atoms are essential for salted preserved food that most people
can eat
.  Music] The
last side of the opposite side
I don't know if I'm skinny or if I can eat
I
'm sure I've seen it on TV Yuji Shishi, the strongest primate high school student,
until such a great
deal- This is wow, other than me and Seg, who's better at surviving than me?
After all, aren't there any other good people in the world
? Humans are the top priority to increase
.
What is the reason why I was able to solve
this
?
The noodles were washed away in this horror neighborhood, but
look at that dripping
water Miracle water born from bat droppings When
I was in 3rd grade, I wondered what chapter elections were, I'm sorry  I can't explain the lower part of the car I can't explain the
house, that is, if I put something on it, the good girl will rot and revive
.
Dozens of times,
it's the realm of that fantasy My
favorite food is the plaster cell
?  Joto
: That's why I'm repeating hypotheses and experiments.
It's not tar My favorite is ferrite sulfide I don't
understand the difficult story As long as I have the
unsoke White grapes will be the source of the people
[music] Let's
do it
I was able to do all the work carefully at the agricultural school.It's super
easy to make
wine.Add a few raisins and put them in a container.Adore I
just mix them every day
.
Hmm, it's about 3 weeks, but it
's about 10 billion times more than I thought.  As long as I have grapes
, I can do this easily
g Point it at the road  Hey, from now on,
I'm going to have to deal with scams and painstakingly
How to make high-class brandy for anime wine
I don't know if it's high-class or not
I thought a
.
They were also distilling at the same time.
]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll teach you the fixed price There are
things you don't understand at home school
[Music] It's been a
year since I started experimenting.
[music
] The pain in my leg from walking moderately the taker
me
ah ah ah
jaygar with a superb view of the night
] the
venue world black rou
goo
good good good
[music]